i i i feel so bad oh are we gonna
get queenie four night age four
queen eight mate is ruby is gonna see
this oh ruby is ruby it's ruby it's no
rubios rubius has played e4 and all
right c3 that might be preparation
yeah c3 d4 it's good preparation it's a
very good system the alapin this is already
actually quite advantageous for for for white
isn't it yes and this is what we expected we
expected daniella to go d6 daniel negrando
absolutely must play the move e6 right now
he hasn't and if if rubius realizes how strong
e5 is anna and e6 just pushing through that that
i wonder if he senses it because uh we've got the
opening principles right in terms of development
and counseling as soon as possible but it's not
that easy to know when it is the right moment to
strike i think when you're starting out with chess
that's one of the most difficult um to feel the
right moment to know when you should push because
the queen side of white is still on develop c
so he could also think is it time to move my
knight from b1 is it time to move the bishop and
so he goes for the development don't be fooled
by this plus 1.5 because it's it's so hard to
even understand why that is uh i i actually
don't even fully understand why it's possible
like give black two moves right black is fine i
wonder if he follows up with oh now he is pointing
out that the e5 pawn could be taken but he should
have seen the move before now black has enough
pieces defending the pawn yes exactly literally i
mean like if he if he he just saw that his knight
he didn't like that his name but that's okay yeah
black has no threats pawn takes pawn and and black
is destroyed on the e file yes it's a bit too late
now by the e5 pawn i wonder if he will notice that
even though he missed the chance there he could
for instance play knight to e4 or bishop to e4
and try to attack the d6 pawn that's a vulnerable
spot to a weak pawn is that even considered an
inter met so like before you take on e5 i guess
it is right so yeah a very strong intermediate
move which removes the defender of the e5 bishop
so danielle would be winning at least a piece
if not more material bishop takes queen takes
knight takes e5 also attacks then the queen and
the bishop on d3 this is suddenly falling apart
unfortunately for rubies but then daniel plays f6
bishop he i think he he also got tunnel vision
there thinking that he needs to make sure that the
g7 bishop cannot be traded so he didn't see that
he had an opportunity that's like a roller coaster
just and then back up and are we about to go back
down again anna i'm really scared it's actually
very natural here for ruby's to either move
his bishop two squares where it was and or one
squared forward and attacked the rook so i don't i
think we're fine i don't think we're or that yes a
bishop to d4 very logical anna you're
right oh you take this with the knight
his chance it's a game where they both i feel like
are a bit too cautious and instead of realizing
that the e4 pawn was okay to take danielle goes
back to f7 defensive move and this is winning for
oh g4 just g4 right or knight d3 and some sort
of g4 g4 was gonna undermine the d4 bishop but
after the trade now the queen is defending the
d4 bishop so the pawn push to g4 no longer wins
a piece for danielle what an exciting game the
evaluation bar dancing to to the beats of rubius
and this isn't anyone's anyone's game
type of position anyone can win this
this is an insane game this is an extremely high
level game of chess and it is taking place on the
only three open files daniel don't play rook c1
that does not work also anna do you take on e5
or do you push f5 f4 like what are you doing here
probably a five or four feet like he should push
f5 but it's not an easy decision to take because
it allows white to keep that pawn which would have
been a passport and rookie six is logical pinning
the pawn very good move that is a classy move so
i was right he does put the queen behind the rook
looking for the better oh my gosh he's all in he's
all in here this is me i'm telling you rubies has
watched too many of our champions tour coverage
but you're you're you're like it sounds like
we're joking but he's he like he might actually be
taking inspiration because so much of
modern chess now is i'm not joking at all
h4 has happened so many times and he was
watching the broadcast every day oh this is
almost a blunder breaking the rook with a tempo
he knows about he knows about the creating a
bigger threat concept but i'm not sure he realized
that after pontix bishop his queen two is hanging
it's that's uh that oh my oh what are you
blowing it's it twice just just take it daniel
on time daniel has been super capture averse
this whole game but he has the time to find it
he's been avoiding a lot of trades yeah no
this is his chance this is his chance to
calmly calculate that that bishop
is attacked by two oh what he misses
rubius follows up with the king side
attack the basics bishop is still hanging
it's just immortal it's standing there and daniel
might realize that that's the thing but now you're
being attacked on the other side and he finds
it he takes it the queen very smart decision
because it forces the queen trade rubius with
the smiler that he missed the the bishop hanging
which unfortunately is another
piece and dania will take it that's
i think it's a lot more obvious that this
knife is hanging oh my oh ruby is just
melting under time pressure unfortunately
he played he was exceptional i mean this is
three straight games yeah but he's just it was
a brilliant game by both goodness daddy didn't
take the night so rubius is still in the game
it's a piece down but he still has some chances
that's a great move because if the
king moves the bishop on f7 is hanging
bishop of eight knight d7 goodness me uh how
how can dania get out of this then i don't know
i don't know i think he has to i
don't even know what the best move is
oh he might have seen seven bishop bishop d4 yep
and i don't even know what's going on oh and he
is he trying to rescue his knight i think that's
what he's doing but now rook h6 wins the night
yeah wow that's heartbreaking and daniel the
bishop and the rook are attacking it so just
one move short of getting the knight out of
a desperate situation yeah daniel is is is
confident in uh in the end game plus it helps that
the other guy's got 20 seconds let's put it make
it very clear and uh keep converting rubios at two
seconds and there the defense of the rook is gone
i think he's trying to create a stalemate i was oh
my gosh i was teaching him about stalemates and he
he thought it's unfair that someone with the
material up would make only half a point but
i pointed out that you always need to make moves
in this case there's no stalemate because there's
still so much room for the king that ruby has
resigned oh i knew this was gonna happen he
said i was gonna go danish and okay let's you know
what i'm actually gonna say this and i'm gonna say
we didn't prepare anything let's see how the
opening goes so that you haven't prepared for this
no no no no no only if it goes well did we prepare
if it goes poorly it's his fault i wonder what
development rubios will go for because i showed
him them no please though i hope it's a mass slip
because i told him that the f7 pawn is glued to
the board i told him you cannot move that pawn
no well what is going on he's he's coming up
with inspiration so the dangerous thing here
oh daniel doesn't go d4 daniel
d4 they're shredding it all
open all right we got a game then this
actually might be brilliant by rubios
yeah that was not my prep i'm gonna distance
myself from that i'm gonna hire a legal team
i i i did not tell daniel negron to play the move
g4 let's just be very clear you have me on record
uh this is court uh you can admit
this testimony in court i did not
i didn't but having said that rubius very
creatively comes up with f6 e5 like and
he's fine he's fine and he's playing faster
g4 was very brave oh daniel and placing his
king on the long diagonal is also maybe a
bit too challenging for for his own safety
yeah all right listen daniel you can't be all
loosey-goosey having a sandwich i mean when c5
has played rubius is storming back like this is
crazy he's playing fantastic now daniel's d4 move
is not even possible he can't go kg3 please don't
go king g3 e4 you resign don't even think about it
it's right there in the line of sight oh f5 is
so good what a move by rubius opening up the f5
is
if daniel realizes that he has to safeguard his
king with one of the pieces that's going to be
under attack he can actually stabilize for example
pawn takes bishop here bishop takes and like queen
takes and daniel might like he's not it's not
good but it's not dead lost or even knight takes
even knight takes is good the other move
that rubios is looking at is bishop e5 i
think that's a strong one too and eventually
he settles with f4 that was one of his first
thoughts he doesn't realize how important
e4 is to his attack he needs e4 to guard
f3 and if daniel takes e4 with literally
anything although some are better than others
yeah black's attack is almost completely gone
if if daniel plays knight d e4 and bishop f3
and he's played it and now bishop f3 and he's
stabilized yeah so now i would expect bishop g4
but that actually allows the rook to take the
pawn right now the rook is guarded that the pawn
is guarded but yeah bishop g4 reopens the pin
i don't know if we're going to get rook g5 but
he just goes all in six all in daniel what are you
doing he's so brave this game the funny thing is
if if 20 moves from here on we gonna get an
end game where there's a backrank checkmate
thanks to the g6 pawn it could still work
out in danielle's favor but he has to survive
this stage of the game because now his king will
be again the target and the black king is safer
now it's important to remember that the rook is
hanging so this this is important to remember why
that's an exchange sacrifice i don't
think volunteers yeah he forgot it's
hanging but it's still a game it is still a
game even if he loses the rook for the bishop
oh he doesn't realize
uh daniel's blunder the bishop well will rubio
see it will he just move the king or will he see
that the bishop is hanging right that's the thing
because he he thinks oh it's over i just got to
play some moves and that's it and he's going to
kill me and he's he might be and he spots it he
spots it it's game on we move the king and then
he takes the bishop he wants to get rid of that
94 is a good idea oh that's a good
idea in fact it's so good it just wins
goodness me that's that's a
killer move if he plays it
oh he thinks he's inside he's winning
need to move you need to move
well that that was not that was not spanish
oh he missed no
oh no a mouse slip in a crucial moment
i i i feel so bad but now the rook is hanging
daniel's hanging his rook but rubio doesn't
see it he doesn't have time oh are we gonna
get queenie four night h4 queen eight mate is
rubio's gonna see this oh ruby's ruby is rubios
no rubius rubius the background checkmate levy
have i told you about the g6 spawn earlier the
funny thing is if if 20 moves from here on we're
gonna get an end game where there's a back rank
checkmate thanks to the g64 anna you were right
i didn't know you're all right i didn't
want to be right i didn't want to be right
my heart is broken i'm relieved because he played
so good and i think honestly if he had more time
he probably would have won both games right
because like honestly and early i'm like okay
no problem here i'm good and all of a sudden
what and then when i was white i was just going
to march up the right side he's doing stuff on the
left i'm not paying attention nothing matters and
before i know it boom boom boom boom boom he's
attacking like every area and i realized like i
was all crammed in and had nowhere to move so like
luckily at the end he only had like 20 seconds or
something and i you know he blundered his queen
and a couple things there but if he had more
time i don't see how i was i don't know how i was
gonna win from white there but after i screwed all
that up gave away a freaking what'd i give away i
gave away a free knife my problem was today that
since my matches from yesterday or or two days
ago with xqc i now have trust issues many many
trust issues because when i played against xqc and
i didn't see the check-in ones and stuff like that
that took a lot of confidence from me when i
played today so not knowing what to do and that's
why i think that i took more time to play uh today
because the other day i was playing much quicker
but today i was like watching at the clock and it
was just like 20 seconds to finish the game and i
started getting nervous and stuff and yeah he
he also played really good like he was always
attacking everything i had like so many stuff
planned in my head and then when i was about to
do the plan and finish it and
win the game he was there and
stopped everything all my plans
so yeah ggs man really good games
you